Hello, my name is Angela Lomang. Welcome
to 3ABN Today Bible Q&A. I'm glad that
you've tuned in. This is one of my
favorite programs and I'm sure it's one
of yours, too. Well, we have a great
program. We have a wonderful lineup. We
have lots of questions. So, we have a
distinguished panel who the Lord has
chosen that will answer these questions.
I'm just going to leave something with
you. God never intended for man to shape
the Bible, but for the Bible to shape
man. Amen. You know, my husband gave
that to me right before I left the house
today, and I he said, "Angie, the Lord
gave this to me because I said, I need
an good and something encouraging." So
remember that he never intended for man
to shape the Bible, but for the Bible to
shape the man. And that's what we're
going to be using today, the word of God
to give you answers. Not our words, but
the word. Anyway, we have a wonderful
panel. But before we start introduce the
panel, I want to give you some
information on how you can send your
questions in. And let's start with an
email address. If you want to email us,
you can email us by going to
bibleqa3abn.tv.
And if you want to text us, you can text
us by going to 6182283975.
Maybe you're an Instagram person. Well,
you can Instagram us by going to 3ABN
official. So, those are several ways you
can send your Bible questions in. Let's
in Let me introduce you to our
distinguished Bible panel. Let's start
with you, Ian Vanderval. Welcome. Well,
thank you for having me. It's always a
pleasure. Bible Q&A is also one of my
favorite programs, too. You know, all
the questions that come in challenge me
and force me to learn as well on top of
being able to learn from these
gentlemen, too. It's a pleasure. It's a
pleasure. Yes. Amen. To be It's an honor
to be on this panel. Yeah. So, thank
you. All right, Pastor Ryan, welcome.
Yes, it's wonderful to be here and I
want you all to know that I learned from
Brother Ian as well. There you go. Amen.
Do send those questions in. It blesses
us just as we pray. We are a blessing to
you. It's wonderful to get into the word
of God together. Amen. Right in front of
me, the love of my life, honey. Wow. I
think you've told that to the world now.
Everybody knows. We all know. That's a
good thing. Thank you. Everybody ought
to know. That's right. That we love each
other. Amen. Well, the Bible always
challenges me. Even though we've opened
that, we discover every time. It's an
ocean that is inexhaustible. Thank you
for your questions. Yes, it is. Well,
Ian, I'm going ask you to open with
prayer. Absolutely. Let's pray. Our
loving heavenly father, Lord, we just
thank you for this day that you have
given us. We thank you for the gift of
life, the air that you put into our
lungs, Lord. And Father, we just thank
you for this opportunity that we have to
just study your word together, to grow
together as brothers and sisters in
Christ. And Father, we just pray that
the things that would be discussed today
would be led by your spirit and that we
would all be drawn closer to you.
Father, we thank you for all that you do
for us. We love you. We thank you. We
praise you in Jesus name. Amen. Amen.
Amen. Thank you for that. Well, I'm
going to start with you, Pastor Lang.
Are you Let's go. Here's your first
question. I've heard some testimonies of
people being taken captive spiritually
by demons. due to witchcraft.
Some had even attended their funerals
and saw their bodies being buried. How
can these testimonies be explained in
comparison with the state of the dead?
This is from Anthony in Ohio. Okay,
thank you Anthony. You know the Bible
makes it very very clear. Ecclesiastes
9:5 and 6. Let's put that into context
first. The living know that they will
die but the dead know not anything. So
when a person dies, they are completely
unconscious. They have no idea of what's
going on. They're not aware of the the
surrounding world. No matter what kind
of life they've lived, whether a good
life or a life where they were involved
in witchcraft, they have no conscious uh
understanding of what's taking place
around them. Now the question also
talked about those who are been taken
captive spiritually uh due to
witchcraft. The Bible does talk about
that in second 2 Timothy chapter 2 26.
The Apostle Paul tells Timothy that they
may come to their senses and escape the
snare of the devil, having been taken
captive by him to do his will. Now, let
me put this in context. Sometimes movies
impact us more than we think. You know,
sometimes we think, well, demon
possession is people spitting out green
stuff and heads spinning and flying
across the room. No. Demon possession
could be as simple as a person who
chooses not to invite the Holy Spirit
into their lives. There only two
spirits. The Bible says, "Try the
spirits to see whether they are of God."
And so, there are evil spirits and then
there's the Holy Spirit. Now, the evil
spirits are evil angels cast out with
Lucifer when he was cast out of heaven.
Onethird of the angels fell with him. So
the devil is not in the earth by
himself. He has evil angels doing his
bidding. And some people have knowingly
or unconsciously open their hearts up to
the working of these demonic spirits.
Some people have even been dedicated by
their parents. I know that there's some
people that talked to us who said,
"Well, their parents being involved in
the occult world dedicated them as a
child to be a gift to the devil." and
they have fought throughout their lives
to come to this point of freedom. But um
when it comes to the state of the dead,
the Bible makes it clear that those who
die don't have any consciousness.
But you know there are those who may be
uh victim of victims of an aberition
because when you are under the influence
of an evil spirit, they are able to
perform signs and wonders. The Bible
says these signs and wonders will be so
great that if possible it will deceive
even the very elect. But it's not
possible. So the devil is able to make
you see things that you don't that is
not really there. Perform miracles that
make make you think a certain way and uh
he's not able to create life. He's not
able to give life but he can surely
create apparitions. That's why people
talk about seeing spirits that they say,
"Well, my mother visited me or my
brother visited me or my cousin visited,
but they're dead." The Bible call those
familiar spirits. So, no matter what the
experience is, in context to what the
Bible teaches about death, the dead know
not anything. They're not floating
around, but there are evil spirits
looking for bodies to possess. The Bible
talks about that. But these evil spirits
are not able to do what the Lord has not
given them the power to do. So, uh, keep
in mind when the dead are dead, they
know absolutely nothing. That's right.
And these people who they say, "I've
seen my dead mother come back." It's an
evil spirit that you've seen. It's not
your mother. And you say, "In Jesus
name, leave. Watch them go." All right.
Thank you for that. All right. Pastor
Johnson, here's your question. A
Christian widow of a spouse who died in
Christ remaries another person who later
dies in the Lord. When they all
reconnect in heaven, which marriage is
honored? Oh, that's a really good
question. And to the person who posed
it, thank you so much because it gives
us an opportunity to look at a little
something here. Well, praise the Lord.
Jesus addresses this very issue in
Matthew chapter 22. And I'm going to
start reading in verse 23. Listen to
this. The same day came to Jesus the
Sadducees which say that there is no
resurrection. They wanted to make it an
issue of resurrection. But you're asking
about which marriage would be honored.
Listen to this. They asked Jesus saying,
"Master, if a man dies having no
children, his brother shall marry his
wife and raise up seed unto his
brother." And now then they they pose
this riddle. There were with us seven
brethren, and the first, when he had
married a wife, deceased, and having no
issue, left his wife unto his brother.
Likewise the second also, and the third
unto the seventh, and the last of all,
the woman died also. Therefore, in the
resurrection, whose wife shall she be of
the seven? For they all had her. Now, in
the Jewish culture, they had this thing
where if a man died, then the wife would
go to his brother to be taken care of.
And so they're asking in this weird
scenario where there were was that seven
total? Seven total brethren, each one
dying in succession and the wife going
to the next in heaven. Which marriage
will be honored? And look what it is
that Jesus says in verse 29. Jesus
answered and said unto them, Ye do heir
not knowing the scriptures nor the power
of God. For in the resurrection, they
neither marry nor are given in marriage,
but are as the angels of God. in heaven.
So we kind of get caught up in the
biology, but we are told that in heaven
we will be as the angels. We do not
marry. We are not given in marriage. But
just because of that, I don't want you
to miss the great wedding. But we're
going to get to that. And I want to tell
a little story. Um when I was pastoring,
there was a couple. She was a widow. He
was a widowerower. And they were living
together. And I was working so hard to
get them to get married and do what the
Lord said do. But they said, "No,
pastor." Because when we get to heaven,
we want to be reunited with our original
spouses. And I'm thinking, brother Ian,
yes, but by God's grace, you got to get
to heaven. That's right. Ah, let us not
live in sin. And that they had a a noble
um what they wanted to do was noble
being with their original spouses. But
no, no, there will be no marriage in
heaven. If you're in that situation, go
ahead and marry. Don't live as married
people and not be married. When we get
to heaven, our relationships will be
different. So, there's no marrying in
heaven, but there's going to be a
wedding. And I want to leave you with
this. Listen to what it says in
Revelation. I'm going to read Revelation
19:7. Let us be glad and rejoice and
give honor to him for the marriage of
the lamb is come, and his wife hath made
herself ready. Christ's church will meet
with Christ. So even though there is no
marrying in the way you meant it, dear
questioner, let us not miss the great
wedding feast. That's right. Where we
will meet with Jesus Christ, the lamb.
And God bless you. Amen. That's one
place I don't want to miss. Do you? No,
we're not going to miss heaven by God's
grace. Amen. Thank you for that. Okay,
Ian, here's your question. It says here
uh I understand that in heaven the stars
on the crowns of the redeemed from the
earth represent the souls each person
has won.
It is said that there will be no
starless crown. My question is will a
person who has not led any souls to
Christ have a place in heaven? This is
from Jennaline in Jamaica. All right,
gentlemen in Jamaica, thank you so much
for your question. And I'm just going to
come out and say that it is impossible
for anyone who has been truly converted
to Jesus Christ to not win souls for
him. It's essentially a natural response
to his saving grace. And there's many
examples of this within the Bible. You
can see it in John chapter 4. I'm only
going to list a few, but John chapter 4,
we have the woman at the well who ran
back to the city and then spoke of
Jesus. We have Mark chapter 5 or the
demoniac who was possessed with a a
legion of demons. He was cleansed and
went and told. John chapter 5, we have
the man at the pool of Bethesda who had
an in or what the Bible says an
infirmity for 38 years. He went out and
spoke of what Jesus had done. And then
in John chapter 9, the man who was born
blind from birth, what did he do? He
started telling everybody about what
Jesus had done for him. So there's many
other of examples that are here in the
Bible. We also read in Ephesians chapter
2 and in verses 8-10 where it says, "For
by grace you have been saved through
faith and that not of yourselves. It is
the gift of God, not of works, lest
anyone should boast." Amen. Now, here's
the key in verse 10. For we are his
workmanship, created in Christ Jesus for
good works, which God prepared
beforehand that we should walk in them.
So, I don't know if you caught it, but
even before we even gave our life over
to Jesus, he has a plan on how he wants
to use us to work for him. And we were
created uh by God to work for him. And
once we accept him into our life and
into our heart, that's exactly what
we're going to do. And he has a plan for
you, just as he does for all of us here
to work for him. Now, many are going to
ask the question, well, what is my
purpose? Well, your purpose is also
found in Isaiah 43 and:7. Everyone who
is called by my name whom I have created
for my glory. So all the works that we
are going to do, it's not for anything
of ourselves. It is only for the glory
of God. That's right. In Matthew chapter
5, we read uh you are the light of the
world. Speaking of us, you are the light
of the world, a city that is set on a
hill that cannot be hidden. And then
also we are told that Jesus is the light
of the world. So when we accept him into
our life, we're basically rad radiating
that light of Jesus to all others and we
can't hide it. It is it can't be hidden
that joy that ex that we feel that
expression of Christ into us will just
radiate to others. Um also we are are
given the great commission that many of
us are aware of but if not you can read
about it in Matthew chapter 28 where
Jesus says go therefore and make
disciples. That is what he what he tells
us to do. And again, as I said in the
beginning, it's a natural response to
when we accept Christ into our life that
we just want to share his goodness. I
know that happened in my life when I
accepted him for the first time and I
really embraced his love and what he has
done for me. I just wanted to share and
work for him. Yes. But some of you also
might say, "What about the thief on the
cross? He didn't share to anyone." Well,
I beg to differ because he recognized
who Christ was even unto his death. And
I believe that people saw this when he
recognized who Christ was and that was a
witness in and of itself as well. He
shares as many will be in heaven. Thank
you. Because even the thief on the
cross. Wow. What a testimony that last
minute remember me when you come into
the kingdom. That was beautiful. Thank
you for sharing that. Maybe you've just
tuned in. Okay. You're saying how could
I send my questions in? All right. You
can email us by going to bibleqa3abn.tv
or maybe you want to text us. You can
text us by going by texting 6182283975.
Maybe you're an Instagram person. You
can Instagram us by going 3ABN
official. All right, let's go. All
right, Pastor John. Yes, here's your
It's a little lengthy, so I'm just going
to start reading it right now. My wife
and I have been married for more than 20
years. We have a mentally challenged
son. Every time we get into a topic
she's not comfortable with, she starts
blaming me and my family for our son's
inherited mentally disabled condition.
I feel I feel really terrible that my
wife sees me and my family as carriers
of these mental health conditions. How
do I navigate constant blame from my
wife? This is from Obie in
Massachusetts.
Wow.
Diving directly into this. The problem
is not your son's condition. The problem
and the challenge is your wife's
attitude concerning your son's
condition. That's where the issue is.
You know, we can't change conditions
that people are affected by. We can't
change anything that happened yesterday,
but we could explore the possibilities
of making changes in our disposition and
our attitude toward the confrontations
that we have to face. Uh when
circumstances are beyond our ability to
change, we have to give attention to the
things that we can change. Attitude is a
huge part of it. I've discovered that um
people have they'll say, "Well, people
like me or people don't like me." And I
say, "Why don't they like you?" They
say, "Because of what I've done." And
some people for years, they hold on to
what a person has done rather than what
they can do. Notice the difference. What
I have done, I can't change, but what
you can do can be a change. So, I I'll
give you three benefits. uh how to be uh
a person with a positive attitude in a
difficult situation. The first one we
can shift our perspective and when we do
that we experience inner peace despite
external circumstances. Shift the
perspective. So here's the challenge.
Now that son may not know or I don't
know what the condition of the son is to
what degree but I sense that even the
son in his challenging condition could
tell the wife's either likes him or
doesn't. Sometimes people might say well
they don't know anything they're they
can't tell what's going on. Everybody
has a sense of perception and I believe
that that child could be impacted
positively or negatively based on what
he senses the attitude of the wife is.
So we can come to a place of giving our
strength and our hearts to God to take
away the anxiety. Philippians 4, do not
be anxious about anything. The Bible
says, "But in every situation like this,
by prayer and petition or prayer and
supplication with thanksgiving, let your
request present your request to God."
And what happens? And the peace of God
that passes or transcends all
understanding. Notice what it does.
It'll guard your heart, your heart and
your mind. It'll change your
perspective. You got to do the second
thing. The other one, this is a chance
to grow and to develop character.
Challenges can become opportunities for
personal growth if we approach them in
the right attitude. Romans 5:3 to5.
Not only so, but we also glory in our
sufferings because we know that
sufferings produce perseverance.
Perseverance, character, and character
hope. Notice in difficulty, we are being
developed. And hope does not put us to
shame. What does not disappoint because
God's love has been poured out into our
hearts through the Holy Spirit who has
been given to us. So challenges are
opportunities to change your perspective
and develop your character and the right
attitude. And I tell you, you'll have a
lot more peace in your home and you are
on the same page. It'll develop your
home, your child, your love, and you
won't you will no longer feel the impact
of being blamed. And finally,
the ability to encourage one another.
You know, we've we've come over we face
challenges and overcome them with the
attitude we have, the positive attitude.
And here it is.
2 Corinthians chapter 1. 2 Corinthians
chapter 1 verse 3 and 4. Notice what
Paul suggests.
Praise be to the God and father of our
Lord Jesus Christ, the father of
compassion, which is what we should
have, and the God of all comfort, who
comforts us in all our troubles. So
that, get this, so that we can comfort
those in any trouble with the comfort we
ourselves receive from God. God is
comforting you. Comfort your husband.
Comfort your child by changing your
attitude. Taking an opportunity for
personal growth and allowing God to be
the power that works in and through your
life. Amen. And pray for them. Pray pray
for the f you know pray with each other
in this world. Yeah, you're going to
have difficulties, right? Sin and
challenges. He's I know he's mentally
challenged, but be encouraged. Just
praying. Take it to the Lord. And by the
way, one day he's not going to be
mentally challenged. Thank you. He's
going to be in his right mind. Amen.
Amen. Plan for that day. Yes. Thank you
for that. Okay, Pastor Johnson, here's
yours. This is from Allison. It says,
"It is a wellnoted phenomena that
happens with people at the edge of
death." Huspet calls it visioning. Yeah.
Where the person sees or hears loved
ones that have passed on.
I have a hard time believing that these
are demonic visions. How does the Bible
explain this endoflife event, Allison?
Okay, pastor. Wow, Allison, this is an
excellent question and and as I'm going
to discuss in a second, I I have
observed this myself when I was a
student on the hospital floor. But as we
enter into the interrogative, let's
let's stand on the word of God. I'm
going to take a note from what Pastor
Lomang just did. We're going to read
from Ecclesiastes. Let's just see what
the word says first. The word says in
Ecclesiastes 9, I'm going to read five
and six. For the living know that they
shall die, but the dead know not
anything. Neither have they anymore a
reward for the memory of them is
forgotten. Also their love and their
hatred, and their envy is now perished.
Neither have they anymore a portion
forever in anything that is done under
the sun. And like to add on to that 1
Thessalonians chapter 4, but the Lord
himself shall descend from heaven with a
shout, the voice of the archangel, and
will call to those who are sleeping in
Christ. But the Bible makes it clear
that the dead are not conscious. They do
not know anything. So when persons are
reporting that they see loved ones or
hear loved ones that is not actually
loved ones that they are seeing or
hearing. But at the same time there are
angels and I have met people and I know
some of us have met people who have seen
angels even as they approach the end of
life. But it is important that we
understand what the Bible says so we are
not deceived. We have a tendency to want
to pray to those who have fallen asleep
and Bible says not to do that. We can be
deceived by certain religions who want
us to pay money to make sure they make
it into heaven. So it's good to know
that the dead do not know anything at
all. That's right. And there are other
things. This is why the Lord wants us to
understand this. But as I said earlier,
I have seen this. I remember being on
the hospital floor and maybe as far out
as a day or two before a person fell
asleep, they would begin reporting
seeing loved ones around and hearing
loved ones. And sometimes even when you
found the person having died, they'd
have their arm stretched out and things
like this. The biology behind the dying,
falling asleep human mind is still being
explored. But without getting too nerdy,
if you will excuse me, we are
discovering that as the mind begins to
expire, there is a release of hormones,
as the integrity of the membranes and
stuff in the brain break down, as oxygen
levels fall, because if you're in the
hospital, you will see that their O2
sats fall, blood pressure falls, and
this causes visions, and that is well
documented. But what I will tell you
though, Allison, and you may find this
interesting, is that not everybody sees
the same thing. In other cultures, they
have a tendency at the point of death to
see things that coincide with what was
popular in their culture. They are not
allseeing loved ones. They're not
allseeing angels. They are seeing things
that are the result of how they were
impressed, as Pastor Lomang was saying,
by what they saw in popular culture. So
let us not confuse real angel sightings
with what they are seeing and let us not
confuse what they are seeing with
falsehood which is actual deceased
people for the Bible says that does not
take place. Amen. That's right. The
Bible says the living know that the dead
will die but what the dead know not
anything nothing at all. Yes. Thank you
for that pastor. Okay Ian. If a person
steals or robs someone purposely guided
by vindictiveness,
will they be held accountable for their
actions? They claim that they are born
again Christians. This is from Sandra in
Florida. All right, Sandra. So, I'm
going to kind of bounce around here
answering different portions of your
questions. I'm not going to go in order,
but the first thing I want to say is not
just this person, but we are all going
to be held accountable for our actions.
Uh we can read in 2 Corinthians chapter
5 and 10 which says for we must all
appear before the judgment seat of
Christ that each one may receive the
things done in the body according to
what he has done whether good or bad. So
either way we are all going to have to
account for the actions that we have
done and even uh we're told in
Ecclesiastes 12:14 that even including
every secret thing will be in the
judgment as well. Um now I also want to
highlight that in Matthew chapter uh 7
because you mentioned that this person
claims to be Christian. In Matthew
chapter 7 we read Lord Lord have we not
prophesied in your name? Cast out demons
in your name and done many wonders in
your name. And then I will declare to
them I never knew you. Depart from me
you who practice lawlessness. So that's
in verse 22 and 23 of Matthew chapter 7.
So even though there are some who may
claim to be Christian in word only may
not show in their that they are
Christian by their actions because the
Bible also tells us that we will know
them by their fruits. Now you do mention
something in here though that uh about
this person stealing. Now we know this
is part of the ten commandments in
Exodus 20 and 15 it says you shall not
steal. But there's something that you
mention in here also where you use the
word vindictiveness. And because of
that, I just want to highlight because
that is it's a strong statement to make.
So if this person is guided by
vindictiveness, by definition, this
means that the person is seeking revenge
or doing something to spitefully hurt
you. So if that is the case, one of the
most difficult things that I'm going to
recommend, and I don't know, Sandra, if
this has happened to you or if you know
if this is somebody else um that is
close to you, just based on reading it,
that's the impression that I got. But if
if anything I think this applies to
anybody if somebody is acting in such a
manner where they are essentially being
guided in this aspect not by the spirit
of God but we know this is comes from a
spirit of evil especially if they are
acting with vindictiveness. Here's
something that is so difficult for all
of us and I'm also speaking to myself
when I say this but in Matthew chapter
5:es 43 and 44 it says you have heard
that it was said you shall love your
neighbor and hate your enemy but I say
to you love your enemies bless those who
curse you do good to those who hate you
and pray for those who spitefully use
you and persecute you. Amen. So if this
action Sandra happened to you, pray for
that person because it is just another
lost soul who is in need of saving just
like you and I or anyone else here at
this table. And I understand if somebody
is trying to purposely attack you. It's
happened to me. I'm sure it's happened
to many others where somebody wants to
purposely hurt you, whether it's in
character or physically. So pray for
this person. And I know that this is
difficult to do because our human nature
wants to come out and react and we want
to get angry. But I I guide you to pray
for this person because you do not want
to hold on to that anger. You do not
want to hold on to that resentment
towards this person because that is
going to be a door for Satan to work
into your life and to cause pain and
suffering to you as well. So pray for
that person not only to heal them but to
help you as well. Amen. That's right.
The Bible talks about overcoming evil
with good. Exactly. Good to them. So
thank you. Well answered, Ian. Well
answered. Okay,
John, you have an interesting question.
Yeah.
Here we go.
This is from Jennifer in Oklahoma. She
says, "I've studied the 28 fundamentals.
Of course, I've agreed with all of them
except for one about jewelry.
There is only one scripture that
cautions against wearing jewelry and it
more so instructs us to focus on our
inner man than our outer appearance in 1
Timothy 2 verse 9 to10.
It doesn't forbid wearing jewelry. Why
is not wearing jewelry a fundamental
belief? Jennifer in Oklahoma. Okay,
thank you Jennifer. You know, as I've
studied this topic through the years,
and you know, honey, the history behind
this, I find this is one of the most
inadequately explained doctrines that
our church has due to one major reason.
The absence of the principle around
which it should be built. Now, let me
just make this point and this is not a
blanket statement because as I put all
the scriptures together that the church
supports this with, it needs to be put
together succinctly. Let me give you an
example. If I say eating pork is not
good for you because of what might you
might get sick or it might give you some
kind of worm, I'm putting the focus on
the impact of pork, right? If I say
alcohol is not good because you could
get drunk or it could give you a bad
liver or you might get some kind of a
some kind of liver disease, I'm putting
the impact on what might happen as a
result of the pork and the alcohol. But
the Bible doesn't put that impact on it.
The Bible puts the impact on the
principle. And what is the principle?
Here it is in 1 Corinthians chapter 3:1
16-1 17. Do you not know that your body
that you are the temple of God and that
the spirit of God dwells in you? If
anyone defiles the temple of God, God
will destroy him. For the temple of God
is holy which temple you are. So in in
reference to the alcohol and the pork,
God is saying don't defile my temple
with unclean food and with fermented any
kind of fermented wine, any kind of
fermented alcohol. He's saying it's
destroying my body and I'm going to
destroy you. I'm holding you
accountable. On the same token, you find
that when you study the topic, let me
just encourage you. Go to my website,
johnlomaching.com,
and there's a three-part powerful video
series called the most expensive temple
ever built, including an outline and a
lesson, and it explains the topic and
the understand of jewelry. But let me
just go ahead and give you this. The
Bible, one of the commandments that we
hardly talk about is the one that says,
"Thou shalt have no other gods before
me." When you study that, you understand
Genesis chapter 35:1-4,
where God is saying to Jacob and his
family, "Go to Bethl, where I was with
you when you fled from Esau, your
brother, and I'll build and build me an
altar there, and I'll sanctify your
family." Notice what he did, though.
Genesis 35 and:e 2. And Jacob said to
his household, "Put away the foreign
gods that are among you. Purify
yourselves and change your garments." He
said, "Put away the foreign gods. Thou
shalt have no other gods before me."
What did they do? Look at verse four. So
they gave Jacob all the foreign gods
which were in their hands and all the
earrings which were in their ears. And
Jacob hid them under the oak tree which
was by Sheckchum. He buried them. He
didn't put them in the house. And then
also you go to the next level. When the
children of Israel came out of Egypt,
the Lord told them over and over to
remove those gods that are among them
removed the ornaments. And only those
who had a willing heart, uh, Exodus
35:22, only those who had a willing
heart gave these to God. And he said, as
long as you wear them, I don't know what
to do with you. God did not identify.
And here was the reason why. Putting
foreign gods on the temple of God was
where God equated his temple being
defiled. Lastly, 2 Corinthians chapter
6:16. By the way, my study takes you far
deeper. Paul says, "What agreement does
the temple of God have with idols? For
you are the temple of the living God, as
God has said, I will dwell in them and
walk among them. I will be their God,
and they shall be my people." That study
will open your eyes tremendously, and
you'll be able to understand the full
context in biblical principle why the
church has taken a stand against the
wearing of jewelry. They're not talking
about the wedding band. That's a
tradition. But the wearing of jewelry
when it comes to ornamentation and um
I'll I'll answer this on the other side
of the little break. Okay. Add some more
to it. Yeah. Because it is exhaustive.
Quite exhaustive topic. Yeah. And the
body temple is the body temple inside as
well as outside. That's right. Thank
you, honey. Yeah. All right. Thank you
for that, sweetie. Okay. Here we go.
Pastor Ryan,
can you explain Judges 11:34-35?
I find it almost inconceivable that a
human sacrifice was condoned.
I read of animal sacrifices in the
Bible, but never human sacrifices. This
is from Eleanor. Eleanor, thank you so
much for this question because this is a
question that allows us to see what the
character of God is really like. And
friends, the question on the table is,
does God condone sacrifice of humans?
No. And in the case of the story we're
going to quickly look at, does he
condone the sacrifice of our children to
appease him? Well, let's stand on the
word of God firstly. We don't have time
to go to these, so write these down.
Deuteronomy 12:31, Leviticus 18 21,
Jeremiah 7:31,
Ezekiel 16 20 and 21, and even the story
of Abraham going to sacrifice his son.
We have clear evidence that God says,
"No, no, no, no. Do not sacrifice your
children. Do not do that. That is not
the way I am. That is not the way I want
my people to be. Nevertheless, we have
this interesting story. I'm going to
start reading in Judges 11 verse one.
Now, Jeepa the Gileadite was a mighty
man of valor, fighting man. And he was
the son of an harlot. Okay? Son of a
harlot. And Gilead begat Jeepa. And
Gilead's wife bear him sons. And his
wife's sons grew up. And they thrust out
Jeepa and said unto him, "Thou shalt not
inherit in our father's house, for thou
art the son of a strange woman." So
here's a man who is the son of a harlot.
But his father let him grow up with the
rest of the family. But when the father
died, the sons of the quote unquote
legitimate sons cast this son of a
harlot out and said, "You are not going
to have our inheritance." But look at
this verse four. And it came to pass in
the process of time that the children of
Ammon made war against Israel. Verse 6.
And they came unto Jeepa, the guy they
cast out, and said, "Come and be our
captain that we may fight with the
children of Ammon." And Jeepa said unto
the elders of Gilead, "If you bring me
home again to fight against the children
of Ammon, and the Lord deliver them
before me, shall I be your head?" So
later on, they needed this guy's help
after they had cast him out. They like,
"Hey, come help us fight the bad guys."
And he says, "If I do this and the Lord
gives us victory, will you let me lead
you?" And they said, "Yes, yes." All
right. And then we get to verse 30.
Well, Jeepa's out there fighting. The
Israelites are fighting. This is
important. God's people are fighting.
Verse 30, we get the vow. Listen to
this. Jeepa vowed a vow unto the Lord
and said, "If you will deliver without
fail the children of Ammon into my
hands, then it shall be that whatsoever
cometh forth of the doors of my house to
meet me when I return in peace from the
children of Ammon shall surely be the
Lord's and I will offer it up for a
burnt offering." So this guy says,
"Lord, I vow to you if you give me
victory, then when I go home, the first
thing that comes out of the doors, I'm
going to offer it up as a burnt
sacrifice." Now, I don't know what he
was thinking because it was the
tradition that when there was victory,
the women would go out and they would
sing the songs. Remember David and Saul
and all of that. So, one cannot argue he
thought his dog was going to come out. A
Labrador retriever was going to come
out. His thoughts were not completely
clear. But it says in scripture that he
was victorious. But look what happens in
verse 34. He came to his house and
behold his daughter came out to meet
him. Oh mercy. And he says, "Oh, what am
I going to do? I've made this vow to the
Lord. I cannot break it." Now, look at
verse 37. The daughter says, "Let this
thing be done for me, but give me two
months that I may go and mourn my
virginity with my friends." Verse 39,
"And at the end of two months, she
returned to her father who did according
to his vow which he vowed." And if you
look at that, it looks like he went and
sacrificed his daughter just as he said
he would. But we don't want to put words
into the Bible. Let's just look at it.
There are two schools of thought here.
One is you'll notice this virginity is
mentioned several times. In fact, I left
a part out. He did according to his vow
when it says she knew no man. Why do we
care whether she was intimate with a
man? One school of thought, Pastor Lang,
is that what he sacrificed was his
lineage. Remember, he was illegitimate
and this was the only child he had. and
that the young lady lived as a nun and
she was mourning that she would not have
children. But we don't want to put words
into the Bible. Another interpretation
is that indeed he did sacrifice his
daughter. There is precedent. In second
Kings, we have the king of Moab
sacrificing his firstborn son. It could
have happened. But we have already
established that God says no. But did
God honor him by giving him victory? No.
God protected Israel. Yes. God does not
honor child sacrifice. Amen. That's not
the God we serve. No, ma'am. No. Thank
you for that. Wow. Well said. Okay, Ian,
we're going to roll straight on to you.
All right. I would like to know how to
have true peace when others around me do
not want to go into the truth. My
husband, neighbors, and friends are not
interested in the truth. Mhm. I
wholeheartedly
sent them invites to church or tell them
about church events,
but they disregard it. I need peace
because this hurts me so much and I
stress out about this. This is from
Jacqueline in Florida. All right,
Jacqueline, thank you so much for your
question and I can I can hear your heart
in it as well. So, but um one thing I
want to say is I commend the passion
that you have for others and I believe
all of us who have accepted Christ, we
all have that passion for one another
and we want to share Jesus as we talked
about in one of my earlier questions.
And something I want to also tell you is
that Jesus feels the same exact way
about his people every single day
because we are his creation and he is
calling to us to have a relationship
with them every single day to include
those who don't even listen. And
sometimes we are really hard-headed
individuals and we just don't listen. I
can think of myself when I was younger.
I remember being a little boy and uh you
know there was a construction site right
by my house and my mother would tell me
all the time, Liam, you better put or
Ian you better put Liam is my son. She
would say, Ian, you better put your your
shoes on before you go out there. And I
would never listen to her and I would go
running around this construction site,
you know, probably because it was all
muddy and I thought it was fun to run
around the mud as a kid. And one day
though, I stepped onto something and
sliced the bottom of my foot right open.
And there was my mother day in day out
warning me, trying to tell me to be
careful, to put my shoes on, and I
didn't listen. So sometimes we can just
be really hard-headed. And Jesus says
the same thing to his people in Matthew
chap 23 and verse 37 where he says, "Oh
Jerusalem, Jerusalem, the one who kills
the prophets and stones those who are
sent to her. How often I wanted to
gather your children together as a hen
gathers her chicks under her wing, but
you were not willing." So, I understand
what you're going through where you're
trying to witness to family, you're
trying to witness to friends. Jesus
experienced the same exact thing. But
one thing I want to tell you because you
did mention you're experiencing some
kind of anxiety uh towards it or it's
stressing you. Philippians and I think
we I think Pastor Lang may have
mentioned it earlier. Philippians
chapter 4 6 and 7. be anxious for
nothing, but in everything by prayer and
supplication with thanksgiving, let your
requests be made known to God. And the
peace of God, because you asked, "How
can I have peace?" And the peace of God,
which surpasses all understanding, will
guard your hearts and minds through
Jesus Christ. So, what I want to
encourage you to do is to continue just
being a witness to these individuals.
Sometimes we can invite them to church.
We can tell them about church events,
but they really don't want to hear it.
What they want to see and what I wanted
to see prior to me becoming to Christ
was I wanted to see Jesus in other
people because I wanted to see a true
Christian, which I never really had a
good example of growing up. The examples
that I saw were the ones who would go to
church and then run to a bar later
afterwards and be drinking. So, what I
would would encourage you to do is just
be kind. Do those acts of kindness. If
they need a listening ear, be that
listening ear. If they need some help
around the house, help them around the
house. Do whatever is needed. Show that
compassion to them and allow the Holy
Spirit to do the conviction in their
hearts because I can tell you one act of
kindness that you show towards somebody
can change their world and they will and
and then accept the invitation that you
have for them. You're speaking from
experience. Absolutely. Absolutely. One
act of kindness. Amen. Thank you for
that. Okay, Pastor John, this is
straight to the point.
This is from Denise in Michigan. How do
I forgive others? Okay. Very direct. I'm
glad you said direct to the point. Yes.
Oh, let me just kind of give you three
very quick points. One, the first one,
it's a choice. It's a choice. That
simple. It's a choice. You've got to
decide whether you want to keep yourself
enslaved to the feelings, to the to the
discontent, to the anger, to the
hostility. When people don't forgive,
they live in a personal prison. Yes.
I've often said people have walked away,
forgot about what they did to you, and
they go on their lives, and you given
them rent in your head for free, and you
are the one drinking poison, hoping that
they will die. That's what lack of
forgiveness does. It poisons you. I've
seen people die of cancer, uh die with
anxiety, always repeating what someone
has done to them. Decades have gone by
and then some people have said, you
know, I'll never forgive that person.
I'm going to take that to my grave.
Well, no. That lack of forgiveness is
going to take you to its grave. You die
before you die. And so, if you want to
be free, the first thing is a choice.
Luke 17:3.
Here's what you do first. If the person
is still alive, you got to pray about
the way you approach them. The Bible
says, "Take heed to yourself." Meaning,
be cautious. If your brother sins
against you, rebuke him. And if he
repents, forgive him. Now, this has to
be done with a person who's under the
anointing of God's spirit. You can't
just say, "I rebuke you for what you did
to me. I You just need to forgive me."
That's not what I'm talking about. You
got to pray. You got to be tender. You
got to ask God, "Give me the right
moment, the right opportunity." Because
if you do that with a desire to just
straighten him out and demand
forgiveness, it's not going to work.
What could you do in that case? You have
to choose. Even if they don't say,
"I did it." Yeah. You got to choose to
let it go. Yes. You got to not allow
yourself. Secondly, the reason to
forgive, it's reciprocal. You see,
Matthew chapter 6 verse 14 and 15. For
if you forgive men their trespasses,
your heavenly father will also forgive
you. It's reciprocal. But if you do not
forgive men their trespasses, and here's
the danger,
neither will your father forgive your
trespasses. If you want God to forgive
you, you got to choose to forgive
others. It's that simple. I mean, this
very simple. It's a choice. Secondly,
it's reciprocal. You give forgiveness,
you get forgiveness. That's the word of
God. Thirdly, it's freedom. It's
freedom. You need to be able to breathe
the air of freedom. Not to wake up
tomorrow and just kind of the moment you
think about it, your face just starts
hurting from anxiety. No. The reason why
Jesus ended his life with these words,
"Father, forgive them for they know not
what they do." Luke 23:34, is he wanted
the record to be clear that he did not
die angry, that he did not die with
hostility, that he did not die saying,
"I can't wait till I come back to get
him." He made an appointment, but he
said, "Father, forgive them. Jesus died
a free man, and you could live a free
person." Amen. And you always say,
"Don't look for it." Right. Right. Don't
look for it. Don't look for an apology,
but you but you have to give it. Don't
look to receive it, right? But to be
free, you have to give it. Amen. And by
the way, we did a whole program on more
powerful than forgiveness. I think I
need to do a sermon on that. There's
something greater than forgiveness.
Thank you, honey. All right, Pastor
Johnson. This is from an in
Pennsylvania.
People always say that Cain was the
first murderer, but realistically,
wasn't Adam the first murderer? His
disobedience plunged our whole human
race into sin, subject to death. Is my
reasoning wrong? You know, I I really
feel where you're coming from and the
logic there because indeed because our
forefathers sinned, we do have this
world of sin. But I would posit that our
children are also suffering because of
some of the decisions that we make.
Isn't that true? But let's just jump
right into something here and look at
murder. Also, by that logic, Eve could
be the first murderer or the serpent. H
interesting. But let's look at it. Um,
Genesis
2 verse 17. But the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil, thou shalt
not eat of it. For in the day that thou
eatest thereof, thou shalt surely die.
That word die, muth, means to destroy.
It also means to be in a state of
spiritual death. Now the death that I
owe is because of my choices. It is not
because of what Adam or Eve did. So that
is important to note. And I would like
to make a very clear distinction between
that death right there discussed. And
yes, yes, there is mortal death as a
result of sin entering the world. But
compare that to what happens with Cain.
It says in verse 8 of chapter 4,
Genesis, "And Cain talked with Abel his
brother. And it came to pass when they
were in the field that Cain rose up
against Abel his brother and slew him.
Slew, kill, that's a different word.
That one is harak. And it means to
murder, to smite with deadly intent,
homicide. And that is indeed the first
time we see that in scripture. So based
on what scripture is saying, yes, the
first person to commit homicide is Cain,
not Adam, not Eve. All right. Thank you.
So true. Okay, Ian.
According to Exodus 20:8, Jesus says,
"Remember the Sabbath day to keep it
holy. As a Christian, will I not make it
to heaven because my job requires me to
work every other Saturday?"
All right. Well, uh, I'm gonna jump
right into this because I know we are
short on time. Yeah. So, but first, I
just want to say it is not up to me
whether or not someone is going to make
it or not make it to heaven. So, I'm
going to leave that up to God because
only God knows the heart. That's right.
But there is a difference between work
and doing good. So, now uh you mentioned
or what we read was Exodus 20:8, which
was remember the Sabbath day to keep it
holy. I'm going to pick it up in verse
9. Six days you shall labor and do all
your work, but the seventh day is the
Sabbath of the Lord your God. In it you
shall do no work. And that word work
here actually means your employment or
your occupation. And this is part of the
ten commandments. This is God's ten
commandments which we are to follow all
ten commandments not nine or not in this
case partially the fourth commandment.
So we are to follow all of his
commandments and not because of it's a
checklist that we have to mark off as if
we're following them but because of our
love towards God. But now as I've said
there's a difference between work and
also between doing good because Jesus
does say that it is lawful to do good on
the Sabbath which you can read in
Matthew 12 and I'm going to read verses
10-2. And behold, there was a man who
had a withered hand, and they asked him,
saying, "Is it lawful to heal on the
Sabbath, that they may accuse him?" Then
he said to them, "What man is there
among you who has one sheep, and if it
falls into the pit on the Sabbath, will
not lay hold of it and lift it out? How
much more value then is man than a
sheep? Therefore, it is lawful to do
good on the Sabbath." Now, what Jesus is
addressing here is the Pharisees
legalistic mindset that condemned
compassion on the Sabbath. He wasn't
just he wasn't justifying the ongoing
occupational labor. Jesus or we also
read in Isaiah chapter 58 that we are
not only to be mindful of doing what we
want to do on the Sabbath but even of
our words as well and the Sabbath as we
read in Ezekiel 20:12 that it is a sign
between us and God. Uh lastly what I
want to share with you is this was
something that I was faced with when I
worked in the army. I was on shift work
and I had to make a decision whether or
not I was going to continue to work on
the Sabbath. And this was very early on
in my Christianity. And I prayed to God.
I said, "Lord, if you would have me,
please help me to find a way to not work
on the Sabbath." And wouldn't you know,
within like just a few days, I heard of
a position opening that was just Monday
through Friday and I did not have to
work on Sabbath. So, if you're being
convicted by this in which the Lord is
sharing this truth with you about the
Sabbath, pray and I promise you, he will
find a way. And I know we're running out
of time, but I want to say this. Matthew
chapter 6 and verse 26, look at the
birds of the air, for they neither sow
nor reap, nor gather into barns, yet
your heavenly Father feeds them. Are you
of not more value than they? Amen. So
God will take care of you when you
choose to do what he wants you to do and
not your own way. Amen. Boy, the word is
rich, isn't it? It's beautiful. Well,
we're going to take a short break and
we'll be right back.
If you're enjoying our 3ABN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's Holy Word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bible qa3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
618-2283975.
That's 618-228-3975.
[Music]
Be sure to include your name and where
you live and then watch through Bible
Q&A for answers from God's word.
Welcome back. I was so blessed by this
program. I hope you were. Well, we're
going to have our wonderful panelists
give us a few closing thoughts. Pastor
L. Yes. On the topic of adornment
jewelry, not only is the inside the
temple of God, but the outside also.
Once again, johnlomaching.com, the most
expensive temple ever built, the full
study is there. All right, Pastor Ryan.
Oh, I urge you all to check that out.
And I praise the Lord that the character
of God is revealed through studying the
scriptures. All right, Ian. Amen. And
and I just wanted to say to the, you
know, the question I asked or answered
last where you mentioned, you know, if
I'm going to make it to heaven, uh, if I
have to work every other Sabbath, what I
want to do is is just maybe help you
change your your perspective on things
because we shouldn't really be asking if
I do this or I do that, am I going to
make it to heaven? Really, what the
question we should be asking is, Lord,
what would you have me to do? And then
just keep looking to Jesus who is the
author and finisher of our faith, which
is you find in Hebrews 12:2. Amen. Amen.
Thank you. And all of these wonderful
guys are preachers. Remember that. And
so you have a wonderful, blessed day.
Thy word have I hidden within my heart
that I might not sin against you. God
bless you. Until next time.
[Music]
Hallelujah.